John Stamos is the proud papa an 8 month
old son Billy of course and only we
joined them on the set when Billy met
his fuller house family for the very
first time it was sort of nervous about
it this is important whooping I've known
these people for 30 years I've talked
about having kids and now you know I
brought my mom did not want to let him
we didn't have a flash of them as as
really little I flashed Jody you know
when she was running around here like
how do you roast the turkey as a quad oh
my eyes I just know we're on me like
very excited andis this season those
excited entities will get to meet the
newest member of the Tanner clan I'm
popping the balloon and live out a
girl-power fantasy we have a Charlie's
Angels episode oh that was really yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
our moms were here for that our parents
come to every single taping and of
course the return of Danny Joey Uncle
Jesse and Aunt Becky kept things
interesting on set
yeah if everything takes longer to do
when any of them are here except Laurie
it's just that the jokes keep coming and
coming and coming and they're just
they're like squirrel distracted so
easily which we saw firsthand in our
interview with John and his buddy Josh
pack who's guest starring because we got
eight seasons of the original show done
with us as children and the three of
them as older children I don't know how
I felt the same way about working with
discovery like Kevin alright season 4 of
full house starts streaming Friday on
Netflix
[Music]